(fire crackling)
- The American west has
seen unprecedented wildfires
this year in Washington
state, Oregon and California.
Which has seemed the most
total acreage for the glass.
Fire is burning in the (mumbles)
of Sonoma and Napa County.
So there's over 475 physical wineries
in Napa County with 700
separate grape growers.
While Napa County only produces
around 4% of all of
California's wine grapes,
they still account for $9 billion
of the, of the more than $30
billion that California brings
in annually through its wine-making.
So this region is incredibly important
to the West coast and
to the wine industry.
The scale of the damage in Napa County
and Sonoma County is hard to assess
because of the evacuated wine owners,
while the devastation is
it's hard tolerate now.
we can bet that it's probably
worth millions of dollars lost
More than a dozen wineries
in Napa and Sonoma County
have reported damages
to their vineyards or
structures on their property.
One of those wineries is
the Napa Valley landmark,
the Castle at the Amaris castle.
and while the Castle still stands
a farmhouse adjacent to the
castle was actually damaged
and not farmhouses holding precious wine
that the winemaker had been
had been making for decades.
- A building that's
about 11,000 square feet,
it burned to the ground.
And in that building, we had a warehouse
with about 120,000 bottles of wine.
It's all gone.
I have to say, it wasn't all of our wine.
Most of our wine is in the
castle, which was on touch
but still thousands of gallons of wine.
The wine value alone was
about $5 million at retail.
It's like a bad dream
and I'm hoping I wake up
and this never happened.
I couldn't believe that the fire
wherever consume a brick
and stone building.
- The wine industry as a whole
is gonna be greatly impacted
by the American West wildfires this year.
Wineries in the American
West and in California
in 2020, we're already facing major losses
just due to having to close tasting rooms
and close wineries due
to COVID-19 restrictions.
And because of the wildfires
in Napa County and Sonoma
County, a lot of the wineries
aren't gonna be able to use 50%
of their grapes and then some even more.
And so that's only tacking
onto the losses already felt
by the pandemic in 2020.
we're (mumbles) probably
for two or three years
because the 2020 vintage
probably wouldn't even be ready
until around 2023.
So that's when a lot of
these wineries are gonna
start seeing same big
losses is years from now.